[Music]
meets Critias Oh
only our Chino Rica hot you know go
[Music]
da-da-da-da-da-da cucumber diced avocado
smooth down
[Music]
Tomica na na koto de sac they accepted a
rich Tennessee GQ Yahoo Jimmy not even a
Morse code on oculus I assume
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie I got a bunch
of requests to do a Dragon Ball Heroes
episode video if you didn't know there's
a new super Dragon Ball Heroes series
meant to promote the game that's a
trading card game that's been adapted to
manga now they're adapting that to the
anime so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'll do as many videos as
you guys want for it if you want me to
do videos for all the episodes obviously
the Dragon Ball super movie is coming at
the end of the year so I'll remind
everybody about that at the end of the
video but if you're not familiar with
this this is actually the third original
saga in Dragon Ball heroes they were
also calling it the first super Dragon
Ball heroes universe mission and when
they talk about universe obviously
there's the teaser from the food
character at the end like this is going
to be a grand experiment in the entire
universe it's meant to be set after the
dark empire saga and the Dragon Ball
super Universal rival saga although
technically I don't think it's
considered canon to Dragon Ball super so
it's not like this is absolutely
critical to what's going on during the
movie it just meant to bridge the gap in
terms of content like they want to keep
Dragon Ball fans sated while they're all
waiting for the Dragon Ball super movie
to get here the weird thing is that it's
not being simulcast by crunchyroll
apparently you can only get this in
Japan right now so you have to be kind
of clever about the way you find it if
you live outside of Japan but it starts
out with Goku and Vegeta being trained
by whis and beerus on beerus planet my
comes running oh my god Future Trunks
has been captured then the shadiest
villain character ever Fuu steps out
from behind a tree I wonder how long he
was waiting behind that tree for my to
queue him up so food tells them that
trunks has been captured on the prison
planet and explains that he's caught up
in this big problem they have to come
running totally not shady but the minute
they get to the planet they're attacked
by someone that will call red Goku I've
heard him called a couple different
names but they just refer to him as red
saying during the series so we're just
calling him a red Goku red Goku goes
super saiyan for our Goku goes super
saiyan blue so I do like the fact that
they just completely cancel each other
out we find out that he's part of an
organization called the time patrol that
it was investigating foo so purposefully
got himself captured but finds that he
now can't leave the planet either so he
was waiting for an alternate version of
himself our Goku to
come to the planet so that they could
both use their powers in synergy to try
and break the chains that we're keeping
them locked there that doesn't work then
foo introduces the idea of this sort of
mini tournament of power that he's
running so you can see it all sounds
very familiar there's a little bit of
fanservice going on it trades a lot on
the tropes of all the Dragon Ball series
like Goku seems surprised when they
introduced the idea that Dragon Balls
like he's never seen a dragon ball
before so more evidence that this isn't
totally canon to what's going on and
even foo calls them special Dragon Balls
seven of them red Goku has won six
belonged to the other prisoners so you
can kind of see where they're headed
with this they'll either have to fight
the other six prisoners and take their
Dragon Balls in order to escape or more
likely they'll have to team up so that
they can all escape together without
anybody dying but with probably a lot of
fighting before that happens like that
last little scene where you find out
where Future Trunks is being held in
that urban area where cooler comes up on
a theme that he has one of the Dragon
Balls so it would be very weird if there
wasn't a whole lot of fighting before
they agreed to work together I mean is
Dragon Ball it's weird when they don't
fight in fact most of the complaints
about the episode is that it you know a
little over eight minutes long in very
little of it is them actually fighting
it's mostly just setting up what the
story is going to be and then letting
you know what it is that they have to do
with like a very brief fight from the
two different versions of Goku but the
big teaser that everybody was talking
about is the evil saying at the end so
if you haven't read this it seems like
they're adapting the manga so you can
actually go read how this story plays
out I don't know if they're gonna be any
changes and I haven't seen any
information about how many episodes is
supposed to be total there are only two
listed right now on the Wikipedia page
but that evil saying that food teases at
the end is actually conv you actually
get a better look at him in the trailer
they drop for the series
[Music]
the whole idea is is that he's too
strong for Goku when he's Super Saiyan
blue so they have to combine and become
Super Saiyan blue vegeto to make it an
even fight but like I said it seems like
most of this series is just dedicated to
promoting the game it feels like based
on the way they're setting this up it's
either gonna be a love it or hate it
kind of series like everybody either
really loves the extra Dragon Ball
content for what it is just like really
small miniseries one-off just to kind of
tide you over until the Dragon Ball
super movie gets here or you're furious
at it being an inferior product because
like if you feel like Dragon Ball super
had a little bit of fanservice and this
is like even more of that so just to be
clear this is not meant to be like the
next big Dragon Ball TV series it's just
meant to be a couple promo episodes to
promote the video game right now it's
saying July 16th is when episode 2 is
gonna be dropping but because Anime Expo
is gonna be this weekend they might drop
new footage for the Dragon Ball super
movie no confirmation on that but the
other big new series that's getting
ready to drop this summer is Castlevania
season 2 there's a bunch of other stuff
like attack on Titan so just expect a
whole lot of new footage from Anime Expo
I'll definitely do a Castlevania video
if you haven't been following that is
fantastically animated it looks
beautiful it's based mostly on Symphony
of the Night and I believe that that
will be premiering on Netflix sometime
in August a little bit later than season
1 premiere last year
what have you done to my god Dracula
so just let me know in the comments what
do you think about all this and look out
for my castlevania season 2 trailer
that'll drop probably Friday I think
that's when the panel is happening so
that's what I'm expecting them to drop
that trailer leave all your video
requests in the comments below too while
you wait for everything click here for
brand new infinity war and click here
for brand new Avengers 4 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]